thank you
nothing nothing
Rachel's all about eye contact we'll be
even be at a restaurant she's like look
at me you know and I'm like I'm like
okay
I'm trying to cut it no yeah I gotta eat
like this no no just like it
in the peripheral
[Laughter]
you ever met this guy oh I'm the dumble
you can't argue there's something about
me you have no idea
[Music]
welcome Nick hey singing the wing and
Ting and ping and it's king and it's
sting in the enchant and chin and the
kingdom with special guest Nick and Chin
like they do with [ __ ] whenever
what's his name's in a movie Michael
Caine with Michael Cain and
[ __ ] that's actually a big deal oh
it's a big oh it's a big deal to be like
the width and the and I'm not sure which
one's more important with or and the
last one whatever they do and my my I I
had that like ore I had that once
I had uh one of those uh I got that once
with or end whatever and my manager was
like telling me like and we got this or
whatever and I was like
I don't give a [ __ ] bro like I know it's
supposed to be special I was like yeah
whatever that's fine but it's gonna be
the middle I don't give a [ __ ] isn't it
whoever's first is a big deal because
when does the movies you know to be like
starring well yeah like Baldwin right
like he's always the first guy yeah
actually there's a bunch of things so
you have the you have the Standalone
Title Credit that's one of the things
you get like they go you get the
Standalone Title Credit you're not with
anyone else you're not with anyone else
yeah then you get the other one where
it's like it'll be like Brendan job
Chris Delia Eric Griffin oh that would
hurt my feelings yeah well I've got if I
was there and it was like several
different names yeah yeah yeah but then
but then even after all even if you get
the big main credit you know because
you're saying like number one or number
two number three on the call sheet then
it's the later one where it'll be like
and yeah or introduce right right it's
better to be that guy than like the
fourth guy yeah yeah well it's better to
be either of those guys than Brian Cowan
where you don't see him on all the
credits and she goes guy in parking lot
right right right right like yeah
yeah yeah
um but that's funny because speaking of
of those all those things I'll be in
Stockton uh tomorrow and then Oakland
the next day and then we're doing Peoria
this is dude chrysalia.com we're doing
Peoria and we're doing Rockford Illinois
dude and I got Savannah you know it's
just like go to chrisley.com I got a
bunch of City Oh wait we're right here
Cheyenne Wyoming I've never been there
dude let's see what's up Boston we sold
the first one out we're doing another
one dude Albany New York Lakeland
Florida Jacksonville Florida it's almost
sold out and that's December 3rd dude
yeah the Wang yeah big boy in Boston wow
yeah you know I heard a better Club you
know what I heard is better than the
language what laugh bostonness
uh next Thursday Friday Saturday shows
are almost sold out laugh Boston your
boys in Boston next week Thursday Friday
Saturday I always tell you mine because
I'm not crying
I gotta go to a funeral tomorrow man
well that'll that's plugged that
oh I think they're live streaming it
check out my grandma's funeral I'll be
selling merch out of my back is it
really uh okay I mean she was 98.
so that's sad I'm sorry ah don't be oh I
wasn't that close with her my dad's like
one of 13. you know she's cool she's 98
and also 300. you're in pain and you're
being defensive yeah you might be right
I'll do Mindless she's just swim every
day though even at 98 used to swim like
a freaking wall or no it's your dad's
okay so it's your dad's mom yeah one of
13 bro one of 13. oh yeah who's busting
that much and having like that's crazy
religious my grandma was super religious
and just just nothing
ow this dude's got a harem it's crazy
he's my hero he does this [ __ ] like you
know how Hollywood will write like two
scripts at the same time and then shoot
one he he had this kid and he was like
and eleven's on the way too like it was
like is it John Wick or your kids
unbelievable that he's like already got
more kids on Deck did you see that yeah
because he'll be like uh when he goes to
his kids he'll be like Michael here's
eight months old and then uh uh Sienna
here is nine months old like a month
baby oh damn it's more I think it's
numerous it must be that oh no there's
like three or four yeah and he has like
he's got different baby mamas he's got
to be he's crushing it now does is it a
sickness like what is it I don't know
what it is it's it's uh maybe that's not
the right word but it's like
he he seemed to be like obsessed with
making people creating yeah some people
are dude some people are I mean like
Elon Musk talks about everyone should
have as many kids as they can because
the number one issue down the road is
gonna the population because people
don't have enough kids so they're not
having enough kids not have enough kids
yeah the population first time is
starting to decline especially in China
they're really limited so they think the
number one problem and also but aren't
there not enough resources and [ __ ] no
that's all [ __ ] but they were saying
is that yeah kind of they were saying
that uh what are you doing yeah I think
that honestly your forehead's still like
that been feeling ugly lately you feel
ugly sometimes I feel like that you ever
go to a mall or open door and you think
you look fly and you see yourself in the
mirror you've been feeling ugly like why
you woke up and what what what's ugly
about you let's let's go over this you
don't agree so I like that so I'm you're
saying I'm handsome I'm saying I guess
I'm saying I get it I just want to know
if you're finally on board with some of
the things you don't like about no no I
I get the whole thing like my eyes are
baggy my forehead's big I look like a
bird I know I'm great I wish I was don't
you know my Skin's fine but I'm helping
um my some days you wake up and you just
feel ugly you know what I mean and uh
today's one of those days and that's
okay dude yeah but you're all in with
your hair I don't know what I don't get
that what my hair what you're like you
were looking at your hair oh you need to
go to the salon maybe that's just when
you caught me but like yeah all angles I
look ugly all angles today some days
just wake up and go it's okay I'm not
feeling it man but there I look good
you never wake up Eric just like today's
not the day man listen sometimes that's
the story of my life
it's all every day this year's not the
year dude you you uh mentioned about how
the you sometimes you think you look fly
and then you go out and you yeah how
about this oh my God I'll be like you
how about them and you just catching
your reflection J crew and you're like
oh I missed I thought I had it and then
I'm like I need a new outfit right now
well no outfit but hold on how about
this speaking of outfits you ever put
some [ __ ] on and you're like whoa this
is a great outfit yeah you take some
pictures you see it next day great and
then
two weeks later you're like oh oof I'm
gonna wear that outfit again yeah and
you put it on and it's just doesn't
doesn't work what is that you're still
you yeah do you agree do you understand
what you understand what I'm saying it
might be the type of a new item you know
what I'm saying like there's that hype I
can't trust Rachel
um that's your girl that's my wife so
like I can't trust because here's the
thing she wants you to look like [ __ ]
yes no yeah if she goes like this if she
goes like this
oh she goes oh that looks so cute on you
look so cute I question I I this is the
response I really want if I'm about to
go to a club I wanted to be like this
where are you going oh okay
you want to be like I want to be like
where you going looking like that that's
what I mean that's hilarious then I know
I'm like okay I'm looking handsome today
I thought you were saying you can't
trust her like if she says you look good
you look bad or you look bad you look
good but you're saying okay
sometimes yeah
but I'd have to tell her like babe not
everybody has the same type as you like
you know like you have a type yeah yeah
yeah but you know what this is the thing
like uh like it is important I've been
talking about this like it's important
to people got to get out and actually
meet people because you don't understand
the power you have in person this
generation so used to being online and
swiping and all this stuff but there's
pheromones and stuff that go on oh dude
you are in person and that and that's
what so when people ask me all the time
hey man how'd you get that girl yeah say
this to me all the time you know why
because I'm dope I'm me yeah exactly why
yeah you get out in person
I know on camera solid six in person and
this personality starts flaring up I'm
I'm a good time on camera I'm a nine in
person I'm a 10 bro I'm both are good
dude okay I'll tell you this much dude
in person oh be around me be around me
bro be around me bro no you get sucked
up dude no get sucked in bro yeah I'm
like this
yeah you like the sun no but the thing
is is I would say on camera he's seven
right
person not solid time I'm a good guy
depends on how I go I start going like
this
ugly
this is okay not too high uh yeah yeah
there's a there's like a you know what I
mean like your angle
you went oh too far oh there it is
imagine if you had to like when you meet
a girl you have to be like I got it hold
on a second let me make sure yeah yeah
yeah oh it stays seriously yeah put on
your heels put in your heels no it's
like when they read your eyes when you
go through clear at the airport yeah
that's what you got to do because I'll
go like this and like move closer face
down I'm like there it is every girl is
clear to me yeah yeah the girl is clear
um how about I always talk about how
there's like there's
there's the golden zone of attract of
attractiveness of Attraction level okay
there's the golden Zone you want to be
best in the golden Zone and the golden
zone is anywhere from like six feet out
to 20 feet out because that's where most
people are seeing yes you know what I'm
saying that's what you want to be the
most attractive but but
if you're not like if you're attractive
Farm far away and then you get into the
golden Zone you're like oh never mind do
you know what I mean it's a problem
close up kind of everybody
called The Danger Zone okay cool yeah
very much but like I I yeah
like I would say you're probably best
looking here you're probably best
looking no in the golden Zone and that's
good
you know far away you might see you and
be like what's that guy all about I
don't know but you get closer to you in
the golden Zone you look right now up
close no you look [ __ ] terrible
obviously and up close
just right in my face you know what I
mean like
didn't even package it nicely it was
like a gift
but most people look terrible I look
terrible up close wow here's the thing
dude here's here's the other things now
up close you got other things going on
100 that's where the family's coming to
play right because I I like myself
oh my God when I'm doing meet and greets
I remember doing meet and greets and
having like a girl say to me like oh you
smell good yeah so whatever that kind of
stuff yeah it's like after they see you
perform or they know whatever they know
you about I mean you have all these
things that are a factor what I'm
telling people out in the world is like
especially the ugly dudes who think
they're ugly they can't whatever yeah
yeah gotta get in person and how do you
just how do you secrete because the
secretion is crucial right through the
show I'm secreting like crazy you smell
like yeah well but you smell sweet I'll
be secreting like crazy that'd be a
great name for Christmas cologne secrete
no [ __ ] no secret no secret like crazy
should be the name of your next special
creation
secretion
dude and I just like pit stains you know
because no but all that stuff but listen
your sense of humor your personality
your smell your your voice your eye
contact your body language these things
are more right these things add to the
equation but this generation is so used
to just being online they don't actually
know because you you get in person and
you you ever ask yourself why am I
attracted to that person or whatever it
might be of course all the time I'm not
attracted to this but you know you go or
like you go well that person's got
something going on yeah it's because in
person it is different get off the
[ __ ] internet let's just take a break
guys let's do it buddy yeah the NFL
I want to talk about yeah the NFL action
is in full swing here at DraftKings
I do and you know what I think that
since DraftKings is the official sports
betting partner of the NFL it's the way
to go it is dude yeah we'll be talking
about here dude we talking touchdowns
big plays even bigger wins new customers
who can bet just five dollar rules on
any NFL team to win if you bet five
dollars you must win what ten dollars
right 200. yeah dude if that's not
enough for you Chris everyone can boost
their winnings with DraftKings stepped
up same game parlays right now for every
leg you add you can boost your winnings
up to 100 percent with payouts bigger
than ever why would you bet on football
anywhere else that's so funny I was
gonna say that too uh yeah it makes
things even sweeter you can also throw
down on stepped up same game parlays
once per game day all season long all
right so download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now and use promo code
cats k-a-t-s to get 200 in free bets if
your team wins when you place a five
dollar bet on any football game that's
code cats only at DraftKings Sportsbook
an official Sports betting partner of
the NFL minimum age and eligibility
restrictions apply see show notes for
details I say eligibility good I'll tell
you what man you boys just recently got
married and you know how I need how much
anxiety I need diamonds and I don't want
to pay an arm and a leg dude you need to
meet my friends at Blue knife I've heard
about you yeah help you make your
celebrations even a little more special
all right blue now offers the largest
selection of independently graded
diamonds and pieces priced significantly
below okay but how many people have how
many couples have they held
Millions oh Millions yeah dude they're
easy online tools let you choose the
diamond shape size clarity as well style
setting and blue Niles bench Jewelers
will help you hand craft her perfect
one-of-a-kind engagement ring One of a
Kind One of a Kind looking for a piece
of Fine Jewelry to commemorate a special
Milestone but still having trouble
choosing Blue Nile shop stress free with
blue Niles 100 satisfaction guarantee
all Blue Nile orders are insured and
shipped in free they're shipped for free
in discrete packaging okay yep make your
moment Sparkle with your guy or gal
Sparkle with Blue Nile go to
bluenile.com use the code Kats to save
50 on your purchase of 500 or more
that's blue now b l u e n i l e.com
code is Kats to save 50 on your purchase
of 500 or more bluenile.com code k-a-t-s
I also feel like it's this and I'm no
scientist but and we'll get to the [ __ ]
submissions but the uh I think that you
ever like not necessarily the most
quintessentially attractive person
you'll be with them but like they're and
and you get to their you know pheromones
and secretions and smell and you love it
I think that that's biology telling us
that will make better Offspring yes you
know what I'm saying I don't know if
that's true or not but I always felt
like that yeah yeah that's how ugly
dudes get hot chicks unless they have
money right if they're strong and all
but see just to pawn it off as money
money also implies someone is successful
confident someone is a go-getter so
women don't like it at all yeah yeah
that's what I'm saying they follow
through but that's what it implies it's
awesome because it's the ugly guys it's
the insecure guys on the internet to be
like oh she's only with you for your
money yeah no it's not money you know
yeah yeah
that's not a good feeling when it's not
good it's not a good feeling to like
think that you have to pay for things
right and it's not a good feeling to
feel like your property that's not a
good feeling that can't last right what
I'm saying though is like you know but I
don't I don't listen yeah it's like when
people watch me game Eric Griffin gaming
on Twitch by the way and somebody will
be like man all these reasons why people
watching news because you were on
Workaholics and I go yeah yeah yeah
that's why I'm streaming right right
right why would somebody watch a 50 year
old play video games if there was
nothing extra especially they can't
smell your secretions well exactly but
what kind of what kind of roast is that
only reason people know you because
you're on the great TV shows of all time
you know when you know when someone says
that to you they go well they're only
with you because of you got money or
were you because you're on TV whatever
right just right yeah okay but but what
I'm saying is this does that imply that
only people that win the genetic Lottery
are allowed to be with people that's a
good question that's a good question you
know what I mean as if like that's the
only thing that's okay so that's a good
you always look at [ __ ] a little bit
different and that's why we love you
dude you come with some real sex
interesting I have a guy who's like say
super like aesthetically handsome right
yes so then no one says was it only with
you because you're handsome that's all
they actually kind of accept it yeah oh
I get it Ryan Gosling I get it I get it
but like I got some Christmas Eric
Griffin they go well it's only because I
go like well that's my Ryan Gosling yeah
dude I'm Ryan Gustin checks all those
boxes but yeah hey do it and also it
wouldn't be good at gaming like [ __ ]
Griffin dude I bet he'd be pretty good
he'd be a shitty Montez yeah
I can see
it God damn now should Attractive people
be the only ones that procreate yeah we
all agree on that now what were you
saying well yeah sometimes two uglies
can make a oh yeah that's true
hell I don't know if two uglies make a
right yeah so you know there's something
I wanted to say about that but there's
the title of the episode you guys
haven't really
what was it what I'm saying is like is
that is why do people feel that way like
why is it like if you win the genetic
Lottery you're allowed to like you know
be out here in the streets and just
getting all the girls or getting all the
guys right and then anyone else that
doesn't fit that now they're making an
excuse they're making excuses well it's
because go ahead can I go yeah tag me in
take me in take me in I'm in so [ __ ]
you know all right
um you're not used to interrupting like
yeah
you see how I gave them the floor yeah
this is like you know jump rope at
school and then I'm it here we go yeah
um but a lot of it is when those people
go only reason you're with that girl is
because of this reason Workaholics or
whatever those trolls talking [ __ ] to
you probably aren't the best looking so
that to them that's their insecurities
coming out being like Oh the only reason
he got that because I can't it's because
he's on Workaholics I actually disagree
with you on one one point bring it a lot
of times too it is Young handsome guys
who are haters as well oh your trolls
are different you know they yeah they'll
look and be like I have because I think
that when older when young guys see an
older guy with like a younger girl okay
they have a thing like why are you with
that guy oh not me you know what you
know they have a thing like that too and
I think it's like because I'm dependable
I never think that I go I get it easy to
talk to I don't know I get it you got a
restaurant or at a restaurant taking a
Nobu and [ __ ] you know when I was young
I couldn't afford that I also think
though guys are using how do I say this
guys are using what they think
women like as and it's not that you know
they're like oh yeah he's you know
they don't understand that they're not
thinking like a woman they're thinking
like a guy do you know what I'm saying
so it's like oh for sure yeah like if
you had to ask like what are the top you
know our female like talking about our
seven female listeners yeah the seven
female listeners that are listening like
tell us like what are your top five
things you look for in a guy you know I
think the list will be different loyalty
for the girl it might be like you know
uh he has a good sense of humor yeah
like [ __ ] humor is the one that you
don't say a lot right that ain't even
top 10 on my list yeah I know yeah I got
the jokes I got it sense of humor
loyalty
um uh uh not money but like safe
basically protective yeah like you know
yeah can take care of me yeah yeah yeah
um and with the guys list you know big
titties yeah his ass cute face yeah yeah
and like I always say and we don't need
all three we'll take two out of three
you know the guys are just different
yeah you're right you know so they just
think that why look at this yeah
speaking of [ __ ] hot dudes yeah is
that Brian Kell in the back with tattoos
someone actually said it was the cats in
the wild Eric on Peds this is
essentially Eric if he had it all
the man at the top of the mountain
didn't [ __ ] fall there Eric Griffin
dude that's the most Eric griffinist
do you know what I mean the man at the
top of the mountain didn't [ __ ] fall
there that's dude can you imagine if you
and I did I'd be like it's a great
escape that guy's [ __ ] cool bro Eric
can you be more like that guy please no
but I I just mean the whole attitude oh
swaggy too this guy's four eight by the
way
everybody
[Music]
's real quick to believe
but when it comes to the good your
[ __ ] my question
[Music]
going man I wish his voice was a little
deeper yeah I think that about so many
dudes you know you can't come in like yo
and then all of a sudden so I think that
we should be yeah I will I'll tell you
I'm glad you [ __ ] ass I will tell
this I think that I and I've thought
this and I saw somebody online that was
really good looking a [ __ ] cool
successful dude and then he started
talking and he had a high voice dude let
me tell you like that no that is I think
when it comes to physical [ __ ] besides
height one of the number one thing that
girls will be like no yep I agree with
them dude if David you ever hear that
David Beckham talk he saw it dude if he
oh hold on yeah like a clivo and [ __ ] oh
and now of course he's swimming in it
anyway a horrible example no no no no
what I'm saying is you'd hear about him
a lot more dude I don't even hear about
how many more no no no he cleans up if
you had a love always like this forget
bro there wouldn't be any of us in the
world
well we wouldn't exist dude that was God
being like it has to be higher yeah
he's gonna get tattoos yeah it has to be
higher cut his wings off sometimes I
feel like on the assembly line yeah
somebody wasn't paying attention oh yeah
you know like so it was like oh they
were checking off like you know good
looks yeah nice eyes yeah great ears yep
good cheekbones yep and then he like
sneezed on voice yeah I was like oh [ __ ]
and with me he's like yeah he'll be fine
and with me he was like God was on the
thing and he was just like this and
somebody started talking to him while I
was doing my forehead and he was like
yeah yeah yeah oh [ __ ]
that's too much yeah but also no [ __ ]
girls on attract those high-pitched
voice imagine like the dirty talk yeah
that's why I'm saying dude
this is related a tick tock went viral
like a year or two ago but uh girls put
a six foot measuring thing at their door
so they know that a guy's not lying
let's see it again that's a protection
hints that say they're six foot
[Music]
right right right
um yeah so that guy
should work on his voice you could also
make your voice I don't know it's just
natural when you're doing this kind of
thing we're all good we have fine voices
that was him I would I would do uh
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the South Park guy yeah hi yeah the guy
at the time didn't fall there the man in
the time of the mountains
it's a little more motivating yeah
can't sound like Mickey Mouse speaking
of hot dudes what's up what do you think
these boys
nope not not high I'll tell you that
right I'll tell you what it's not be
high it is
it's unfair bro the tats are sick it's
not deep
this is my shitty submission to kinder I
don't even know if you guys are still
doing that or not you want to reboot it
or something like that I like it um I
know you guys have a lot of love for OKC
as far as the comedy Scene goes we're in
town dating scene on the other hand is
questionable to say the least so I just
wanted to try to use all my Avenues see
if there's anything out there
I get it I know that right I'm furious
right hey guy go outside [ __ ] outside
somewhere magnificent no he is though
but it's Oklahoma all the girls with
like AJ Hawks
I want to go along with this
in the South yeah come on dude this
guy's doing he's in Oklahoma
is this sound checks walk like this and
their titties go like this bro they go
on the downswing man and they took a
step down there titties
their titties are dapping all the time
yeah sorry camera hold on and they
cooked like peach cobbler and [ __ ] still
got my forehead in it um they cook peach
cobbler
like these guys that go on The Bachelor
they don't really want to be on The
Bachelor they want to be famous so I get
it you want to be on on some uh on but
maybe he's just not making a connection
in small City in Oklahoma he's like hey
fellas help me out here and you guys are
hating on them you don't need you he
could go down hey dude spend two days in
Austin get your dicks up now dude
Oklahoma has I don't understand yeah I'd
agree with you I I mean maybe there's
something I don't know but like the
South always
you keep saying that's the hottest you
keep saying the South and maybe for work
he can't travel to the other great
states in the South he's stuck in
Oklahoma where there's tornadoes in
football that's it just Google hot girls
in Oklahoma please
you could Google hot girls in North
Korea who gives a [ __ ] they're gonna
find what's the code in a day you
the man in Oklahoma finding the
hottestine I think this guy's gonna be
fine he said he is bored of the girls
he's meeting in bars like you can't go
down
dude honestly hang out at a [ __ ] Cafe
for a day bro yeah dude go to Target
daddy there's so many hoes in Target
yeah the Oklahoma Target that's such a
but it just it's not a fun thing though
at least you're eating and [ __ ] Cafe
yeah like a cafe in Paris dude he's in
Oklahoma she's gonna pull up at a cafe
yeah dude you go get like a coffee and a
bagel you sit down you're looking at
people Eric we're good bro this guy you
guys don't know [ __ ] I'm doing it like
you pull the paper out and then you look
it's like this you look over and see
someone you go
[Laughter]
hey hey you know what if you if
somebody's like you got one of like you
got the business paper out you know yeah
yeah yeah and you just you give them a
little
bit
[ __ ] that's how you meet people I I
get it bro or like go to Whole Foods
that's how you get chicks man I give
them the flat yeah
it's an older and then maybe you'd lean
back just a little bit just to see yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
and she's like who's you do you do a
little bit to see the face and then a
little bit more yeah yeah yeah yeah
who's that that's an older thing go to
Whole Foods man hang on the produce
section I get it and they just go these
chairs are popping today and then
conversations these chairs
well you speak weird you speak weird but
Brandon is an attractive guy yeah right
because
she would be like it was this
day you couldn't get any blind girls
yeah hey nor would I want to I think
that and that's why no blind girls are
in your DM well Braille but
they're they're going to get a fine ass
deaf chick
I I would like I think it would be cool
to be with a blind chick like a uh like
you know what I mean I'm all for I'm not
I would never be like death would I be a
problem it'd be a problem because you
got to hear me bro nothing
[Laughter]
Rachel's all about eye contact we'll
even be at a restaurant she's like look
at me you know I'm like I'm like okay
I'm you know yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm trying to cut it no yeah should I
mean it's not gonna eat like this look
at that no no just like it
in the peripheral
I love it dude but we gotta take a break
okay we're having so much fun dude yeah
and I want to talk to you something I
want to talk about something called
draftking Sportsbook if you live under a
rock and don't know what it is already
okay Chris you're a huge NFL fan and I
love NFL action and it's in full swing
well guess what draftking Sportsbook is
the official sports betting partner of
the NFL yep week three baby my Bronco is
going to win so bet on them dude yep if
you like football and making money new
customers with DraftKings can bet just
five dollars and what do you win five
more dollars right two hundred dollars
what yeah oh and that's not enough for
you Chris cool you think you know your
NFL bro everyone can boost their
winnings with DraftKings stepped up same
game parlays right now for every leg you
add you can boost your winnings up to
100 you know what it's like it's like
I'm like I'm like with pounds bigger
than ever I'm just like why men on
football why would you go how would you
do anywhere else what are you doing yeah
so download the DraftKings Sportsbook
app now out and use promo code cats Kats
to get 200 in free bets if your team
wins and you place a five dollar bet on
any football game that's code Kats
that's cats only at draftkingsports
DraftKings Sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the NFL minimum age
and eligibility restrictions apply see
show notes for details hey Chris you
ever be on the road you stop at a gas
station see some of those weird erection
pills or the the shots you can take and
it's like Dino 5000 get hard now it's
kind of weird dude bro and here's the
thing it's tempting don't be wrong it's
tempting yeah because you watch anime
and get weird yeah you like the game you
like to be a rock hard for a long time I
get it but a long time you mean several
years yeah you don't want that and also
those things are awful for you man
that's why my friends at Joy mode is
here to save the day whether you're
happy or unhappy with your performance
in the bedroom why not add a little
turbo boost to your dick game you know
what it's like it's like sexual
performance booster it's it's a
pre-workout for but for sex I'm talking
about out uh you'll go Great Links to
biohack your way to better mental and
physical performance but what about the
bedroom what about when you're doing the
horizontal Mambo yeah dude Joy mode
makes natural and science-backed sexual
wellness products for the Bros their
sexual performance booster is like a
pre-workout but for sad the sexual
performance motor is booster is designed
to support erection quality and firmness
and I've never said those words
altogether before but uh it's very true
yeah yeah listen man they're really
gonna boost that sex game for you man
all right how do you take it all you do
is tear open the sachet all right mix
with six eight ounces of water just like
your favorite electrolyte packet all
right for best use consume anywhere from
45 to four hours so you got a four hour
window there you'll notice better blood
flow better erection quality and
firmness I think rock look let's get
down to brass tacks you want to spice
things up in the bedroom and boost your
sexual performance and do it naturally
without nasty prescription drugs we have
a special offer for the king and the
sting and the wing audience go uh to use
Joy mode dot com slash kits or enter
Kats cats at checkout for 20 off your
first order that's
usejoymode.com cats for twenty percent
off your first over order thanks Joy
mode thanks Joy mode
oh we didn't help this guy at all if
you're uh this guy doesn't need help
yeah if you're a girl and you want to
date will he's asking for us to re Bring
Back Our dating game send in video you
know what I'll find you now if I would
find him this guy
you have to do this he should come on
and we'll find him some you know you
know what I mean some Dime Piece because
let's hear his actual problem with
Oklahoma uh he just said he's no no he's
saying love when we if we get him off if
we get him on if he's like man I've been
dating this girl this what happened he
reminds me of my friend that like and
this is a hot guy thing my friend said
to me he was like yeah you know if I
date a blonde the next one oh that's
crazy she can't be a blonde but that guy
doesn't even know what he's saying that
guy's a [ __ ] [ __ ] and my thing is
like my thing is like he's blocking is
she breathing
you know this you know what I mean I
don't I don't have the luxury to be like
what a laugh [ __ ] three the last one
didn't have yeah
my ex was a person this time I need a
person again so so this is like he feels
like that kind of guy right right he
seems picky I'm not getting that vibe
from him no I I get it though he's
probably very picky right
yeah
I understand
what you're saying yeah and they're
young and they're just trying to have a
good time he's like damn I'm looking for
something real here yeah yeah but then
go to Target
yeah you got this guy's gonna be fine
he's pissing me off yeah oh confessions
yes yes
oh this isn't patrons yeah not patrons
we can't play it next week yeah patreon
gang gang buzz buzz guys uh you guys
confession
and then my girl been trying to conceive
for uh
quite a while now a little Dusty know
that I've had a vasectomy dude get out
of color
or should I just keep on practicing oh
my God let me know
he's a monster wait hold on for a while
so you've been together for a bit she
doesn't know about this it's this guy
hey dude this guy's priorities are and
he's just like telling us like hey guy
well first of all
wait
I want to talk to this guy like is there
more he doesn't want to have kids man
but don't have kids and he doesn't want
to wear a condom you think that's what
it is yeah I mean again it's also [ __ ]
up though because if I don't know how
old his lady is but if she's under the
impression that you can have kids and
just not happening she doesn't think
it's her it's so [ __ ] up yeah yeah you
gotta tell her immediately and he can
reverse the vasectomy yeah true true you
can right it's just he's a monster also
don't give a second right no don't get a
vasectomy I feel like that's super I I
don't know not natural I was talking to
a guy I mean yeah you dated a girl with
fake tits you know what I mean I'm
saying this is also a guy perspective
you know a girl I mean it's not natural
also to take you know some hormonal
birth control that's messing with your
system every single day you have to take
it just so you don't get pregnant Eric
shut the [ __ ] up
what are we trying to do here man Eric
with your girls too much man you know
what dude
you're being a [ __ ] [ __ ] right now
I saw this great
thing for my chick and it said like you
know
uh I she goes I took a pill he won't
take a pill so I can get a dog but I
took a pill every day
wow that's a hell of a tick tock
that's what I'm saying yeah it's
perspective with the guy's like guys
going I don't want it yeah yeah no I
don't know I want to take a pill for
your dog yeah I mean I agree with that
guy yeah
I think that uh yeah I don't know if
it's like I was talking to a guy and I
was like
um just a normal guy yeah no he was
another comedian and I and he has a
vasectomy and uh and I said you know
he's married and uh his kids and stuff
and I was like so you got to visit me
because you didn't want more kids and he
was like yeah I don't want more kids and
um honestly like I was like it's just
it's not worth it to me like to me like
what if you do want more kids number one
number two
surgery you know what I mean it take it
takes like a month to yeah yeah sit on a
bag of peas they slice just into you
it's just a lot and they're shooting
ghosts and I said and I said to me it's
just not worth it just like pull out you
know or whatever and he was like oh he
said uh the idea of
um you know completing in my wife
um God raw well you got to do a clinical
so you guys are [ __ ] restricted on
YouTube
um completing in my wife was this was
this Dr Drew yeah the idea of completing
in your wife he said is Dr Phil
Dr Phil is that you did Dr Phil I said
Dr Drew oh got it okay that's okay
he said he said for the rest of my life
brings me so much joy and I was like oh
okay probably to both of them fair
enough yeah fair enough then yeah fair
enough
I like this oh yeah you know true yeah
but I know this isn't patreon you're
talking about cream pies we're trying to
get a hold of a vasectomy guy I have his
number I told him we'll keep him
anonymous uh Mark's texting right now
okay it was just gonna come on and like
try to get off to get vasectomy yeah at
the end of it we're like all right let's
give it a second all right I guess we'll
see you tomorrow at nine
that's wild okay yeah you got it I mean
you have to tell her bro that's oh no
that's not it's gonna hurt you at all oh
you piece of [ __ ] but check this out
though let's play it out okay how close
is he to this well that that's why I
want to give my phone because what I'm
saying is like that's gonna be a that
could be a deal breaker for her that's
gonna be absolutely that's like cheating
oh it's awful it's it's like it's
dishonorable it's uh but also let her
move on like make sure if she wants kids
you gotta let me know what I'm saying is
like this is a hard thing to admit to
his wife this is gonna be so yeah it's
gonna be well if it's been five years or
something yeah ten years but yeah
how about this how about this if he's
going to any doctor's appointments with
her because they because she made it
seem like it was her like if there was
if there was just one doctor's
appointment where she went to find out
let me make sure I'm okay this is a
betrayal
[Music]
I mean because the doctor checked her
out and be like she's fine dude let's
check you out and if he goes in they'll
know in the heart PJ doctor's just like
show me your taint to the guy bend over
Sprint oh I see the problem are you
shooting ghost loads I see the problem
all right well let's go to the next one
and then if you get the guy in the horn
cool if not it's fine he probably
doesn't want to I assume but I think he
sounds like a liar I think he keeps it
going reverses the vasectomy and act
like everything's fine they'll have a
baby like it's a miracle hey man
for two weeks
and uh so I could stay home from school
my parents took me to the hospital four
times wow had a specialist fly out from
Ohio uh two or three CT scans a couple
MRIS
it was all because I didn't want to take
a test so I uh I got shot up with drugs
for two weeks to try and make my
imaginary how they go away just kind of
solid feel bad about it uh gang gang
this is just like the vasectomy guy well
there's a point when your lie you just
go well I gotta keep going with this or
you just pull the shoe like ah the
headaches gone we don't need to gotta
fly out from San Jose
he should have like at certain point
like this is getting out of control yeah
yeah but I'm out but that's you're in it
now you know you're still gonna take the
time but you probably love this
attention from your parents in a way
that they really showing how much they
love you and care about you and he's
probably like wow everybody you know
this is what happened Dad really does
love you yeah yeah he's constantly fix
illnesses Mommy Dearest with a mom Force
the girl to be sick all the time of
course of course not but I uh
there was one called it was called run
on Amazon same premise wait a minute
this is a true story though and what was
this about it
[ __ ] they got the Make-A-Wish thing they
gave her houses they gave her all sorts
of [ __ ] so that's mommy there so it's
not that it's the it's it's a book so we
know Brenda didn't see that
um yeah the only one with it
um on Amazon
um no it's it's a maybe it's not called
Mommy deers it's something uh you're
talking about the one on Hulu yeah yeah
yeah it's [ __ ] great yeah with uh
that girl is a good actor
I know what you're talking about and
then it ends spoiler they end up killing
the mom the boyfriend and the girl
killed the mom okay true story it's with
the picture yes but there's our cats in
it God that feels good friends god it
feels too good really good man
I'm getting vasectomy yeah but you don't
have to worry about
um all right just in case I don't want
him to have a kid imagine you're gay you
get a vasectomy for just an idiot oh
there it is that's it right there the
ACT I mean
Mommy Dearest just made up Mommy Dearest
like so weird show it just [ __ ] it's
called It's called The Act I'm like it's
called done with the wind it's so
different
you guys got mother problems you know oh
yeah
are you my therapist
I think it was also on Hulu yeah this is
just yeah this got movies called I love
my mother what is it with the cars and
the guy one one is an underground Street
racer and the other guy's an undercover
cot oh faster than Fury I thought I love
my mother
this movie was the same thing oh right
mom was keeping the girl sick she's a
good she figured out no she's phenomenal
what do they call that um
yeah yeah
yeah so this is that this one was that
one the other one is a legit true story
yeah it was you're wondering no it was
I've seen it on and then the boyfriend
got like life and the daughter who
basically convinced the the boyfriend
murder got like she's almost out now I
think she's got like six years it's nuts
that just she dealt with so much abuse
like the mom would force her like a
feeding tube yeah you know she was
normal forced her in a wheelchair her
entire life it's a that's a crazy
disease bro the munchauser by proxy
right it's just like wanting someone
else to be sick so you get the attention
and [ __ ] it's just [ __ ] odd by the
way dude I think you have cancer
um
you might be right wow
got so serious um all right cool uh yeah
the caretaker for child most of them oh
oh yeah let's go to this guy all right
just a mustache makes me interested okay
low voice or high voice uh I say low I
say [ __ ]
yo King sting Wing sing Nick Chin how's
everybody doing yeah I gotta quit can't
understand it for you crooked teeth he's
watching football the other day
um and I saw Russell Wilson get booed by
Seattle [ __ ] um yeah I was just
wondering what you guys thought I'm a
Packers fan I wouldn't have booed
um far when he came back even when it
was on the biking and beat you guys
anyway
um yeah that's my king or sting it uh
thanks for everything you guys do
appreciate it all gang gang buzz buzz
soar
see I like this guy I apologize for
making fun of him before the question
it's a good question it's [ __ ] up
because all this [ __ ] Russell Wilson did
for the Seattle Seahawks with nothing
what get carried by no no one of the
greatest defenses ever but he won the
Super Bowl and then it's statistically
compared to Aaron Rodgers the defense
won the Super Bowl Legion of Doom and
the second year he threw an interception
instead of winning the Super Bowl look
at the stats compared to everyone he was
fighting and fighting and fighting and
fighting they never signed anybody yeah
and they tried trading them before he
wanted out but but Eric you think it's
okay to boo yeah
no he did it if he did no they wanted to
trade him right now no they tried
trading him like oh [ __ ] that I'm out
dude they tried to trade him because he
wanted out no before that that's what
made him want out he found out because
that wasn't four he got it wrong you got
it wrong he found out they were trying
to trade him so he's like [ __ ] Y'all no
this is my Denver bronces
put out a thing talk about oh these are
the four teams I want to play with yeah
none of those teams wanted him and now
the Broncos wanted them we got him and
look what's happening
who just beat Houston who's your team a
sucky who's your team Houston all right
oh my God what happened why Houston
sucks but why is that your team and no
no I'm not saying Houston's my team
it's early in the year Russell Wilson he
got booed by his home team he got booed
by Denver yesterday or month Sunday
because he was playing like [ __ ] maybe
there were ghosts in the stand maybe he
wasn't being booed they were just maybe
they were ghosts now Nikka like this
when I was there when I was in uh
Appleton Wisconsin I drove 30 minutes
and went to Lambeau Field that place is
mad yeah I'll be in Peoria
I was just in Milwaukee thanks for all
the people that came out a lot of King
of The Sting fans came thank you
Milwaukee I gotta show in Savannah dude
I think that I think that Russell Wilson
is one of those guys that just play
football stop being trying to pretend
you have a personality on the internet
the guy he doesn't it's Sierra his wife
who's always out there you know he's so
insecure that they can't play Futures
music during the warm-up in the stadium
that is something I don't believe the
baby mama the baby daddy's future I
don't believe that dude that's facts I
all right you know why you should listen
why
dude I feel like no I'm trying to
contain my anger okay I think that even
if Russell Wilson did say that he was
probably like yeah why don't play that
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] trying to get all in
the thing it's like I kind of understand
that to be honest oh I'm with him yeah
but now the son's name is future it is
yeah little future
Junior mini future
wow around the house
yeah but Russell's always like that I
would call him past
hey little past you know what I mean
yeah
the hottest is
um when future was asked about whatever
food that was and he said Sensational
bro I would have kissed him right there
he's hot as [ __ ] dude I'd [ __ ] future
okay you said
yeah I'm saying I'm not gay but is it a
bottle of red wine and Jared Leto late
at night all right it's not no future
the future's way hotter than Jared
they're both hot right let's be cool no
Jared Leto is wafey dude Future's hot as
[ __ ] Define wafey dude Define way
Finnish [ __ ] and like
it's just like he's not manly the
future's like look at that bro
I'm not even [ __ ] around that guy's a
good looking dude compared to Jared Lana
are you better bro I think he's better I
bet his secretions are [ __ ]
unbelievable yeah not in your mouth hard
but the thing is about uh not with that
Jared Leto's 50 something dude oh [ __ ]
Futures in yeah future won't look that
good at 50. I'll give you that no no no
black don't crack
yeah yeah sometimes your level's 50 bro
he's been wafey bro oh bro come on he's
all done up bro he's all done so you so
you're also attracted to Stephen Tyler
no Stephen Tyler looks like a [ __ ]
warlock next to him he's all done up bro
see the makeup on him no I do I've seen
him in person
yeah what are you talking about oh well
that's my grandma who passed away
but she didn't realize that eating
king-sized snicker bars all the time
would add weight he does look like
somebody's grandma Yeah God damn Steven
Tyler what happened but he's like 80.
looking like that though yeah [ __ ]
Jared Leto's 53. all right Flawless he
looks better than anybody I don't come
on wait who what he looks younger than
anybody in here he's 50. in that picture
but he's got makeup on and it's [ __ ]
okay okay put makeup on me bro I look
[ __ ] crazy good
and he can sing I don't know me too dude
not like that 30 Seconds to Mars you do
have two handbags going on yeah I know
but put some makeup on me bro I look
fantastic okay all right wider than
Chris
big fan not gonna lie crystally is the
one that brought me over but I'm loving
all of you guys
um my name's Nicole
um I'm 26. but you're staying for you
Twilight
rocking the Grays naturally oh yeah oh
she's 26. oh yeah she's Jean Gray from
X-Men yeah yeah Eric or should I dye my
[ __ ] hair Vibe with me on this Jean
Gray it's Rogue who had the white hair
would you stop talking about comic book
stuff I knew it was Rogue thank you Jean
Gray they bring up Jean Gray Nick I
think they're off also I give Daddy has
some Grays and I dyed it before and
everyone told me not to yeah yeah I
don't I look like Jay Leno
dude I want to have I think it's awesome
to have gray hair like that me too but
also if you died it would look good too
ah but don't diet that's it I mean dye
their [ __ ] hair you know
let's go from a Game of Thrones try
getting out of the game she's also a an
attractive female oh she could shave her
head yeah yeah now pull up Rogue yeah no
no hey don't pull up the actors pull up
the [ __ ] the cartoon we ain't talking
about Africa dancing this is what they
did that's Rogue see that's what I'm
talking about
[ __ ] yeah there you go that girl's road
yeah that's hot get a rogue tattoo
that's hot I mean it's mostly her body
and face but those comic books back in
the day I don't know if they're woke now
and the girls are extra thick and you
know yeah definitely but now back then
dude the Rogue and storm in the comic
books Daddy was young and Jack and boys
back you were totally wrong about Jean
Gray I said no I think so okay so to get
back to what this girl's saying I think
that she should do whatever makes her
feel comfortable she's lucky she's in a
situation that she she's a very
attractive you know female hair could be
green yeah it's not like we're talking
about [ __ ] librarian and [ __ ] this is
a you know so it actually and it
actually looks kind of nice it's like a
nice little streak a little flare it's
also a conversation honestly some women
might just do this just to [ __ ] put
it in here so but I also think you'd
look good if you colored it in you know
I I think I think it makes her unique or
just did whatever girls do you know how
they always do in their hair yeah yeah
so it doesn't even matter yeah I like
the story but yeah but don't you know
thank you for being we're glad we
brought you over to this show whatever
it's called now and um you know thanks
for listening and congratulations I'm on
the show too she does look like yeah she
does look like Rogue from the movie yeah
yeah a little bit she's hotter than that
and a pack when it's out of pack when
I'm I know okay so
um yeah
[Music]
what's up with all the Attractive people
are stinging
Road Dome
yes it feels fantastic
thrill gets get your blood rushing
but
also dangerous yeah
going down the 405 getting sucked off
you hit traffic
it's dangerous but it feels good so
kingdom are sting it Road dumb honestly
dude
I I it's too much unless she's really
about it and she's driving and she does
it
yeah
oh
right right yeah
um that here's the deal uh I I don't I
there it comes a point where it's just
like just pull over and focus on it you
boring though huh nah bro I'm not I want
to feel all of it no spontaneous here
like if you're in like a higher car okay
but like if you're like in some little
car and you're on the 405 people are
driving by like what up you know you
like that you're saying but this I don't
know there's also it's rare I uh vouch
for Teslas because you can't [ __ ]
stand them but they do drive themselves
so you can put in that driver mode and
get that so she could be driving oh yeah
yeah and sucking driving and sucking the
Tesla shout out to Tesla you're the only
good thing she's giving you head huh the
Tesla Tesla you're about to buy that's
what they should call not drive yourself
self-drive just call it head mode
head no suck off mode head mode
then all of a sudden like the lights dim
a little ball comes out
is such an Eric Griffin joke bro that is
such the lights dip and then the thing
comes down and they're like you know
you'll never find it's just something
sexy music
oh no What a Feeling it'd go
I wish Tesla did that
head mode you'll see me doing this at
The Improv this weekend yo get the [ __ ]
out of here with the everyone good guy
and girl what's up with the good good
looking [ __ ] hey the show changes and
look what happened Jesus bro feel left
the people got better God damn
everyone's hot as [ __ ] the future's next
hey what's up I just want to say the
call the show is Sensational
show sensation all right and I heard
there was some talk about sucking my
dick
someone said headmo she got a little Uma
Thurman you guys I have a king
interesting it for you
bangs no have room so we have to do it
um but then I went ahead and did it and
now everyone says how cute they are so I
need to know I don't know what to say
cuteness because I already did it and
now they can't say that she pulls it off
she does but also are cute you Kelly
kapow let me know what you think um I
will say I can't put my hair behind my
ears because now I look like Tiger King
and that's not what I'm doing
um but otherwise love them it's cool let
me know what you think she pulls it off
she does she does she does right you
should be supposed to say you should
wear bangs though right cover your
forehead yeah I should get pregnant yeah
I think that
you pull the bag there's another face
hey Nick I don't think she's referencing
uh him I think she's referencing Carol
Baskin because she did the bangs with
the hair I think bro [ __ ] wait till
we're done laughing at my joke to say
that bro God damn it we need to
experience hit him with the no I'll do
it
that's a good one chrysalia.com dude I
feel and I'm kidding and I'm getting a
woo-woo one no she looks great on it I'm
gonna be honest she looks great with the
bangs not a fan of bangs I am not a fan
of banks that's all I'm saying um I
think that probably
you she might I would I can't I don't
never see it she probably looks better
without bangs but hey here's the thing
she does look great with bangs she's an
attractive girl she's gonna have [ __ ]
dreadlocks and pull it off right if
you're sexy enough you can have shave
your head she could be fooled read about
preference not a fan of bangs as long as
she looks good I would give a [ __ ] yeah
okay as long as she can pull it off okay
it's more to me bangs is more of uh you
should have bangs though yeah yeah it's
more of a bangs is like to me like it's
like a kink it's like okay that was fun
now where's your real hair you know what
I mean like if we're gonna be in a
relationship let's grow it out yeah but
also Bang's a little bit
right like it's a very like like high
school like oh Middle School like a
cutesy thing yeah right like
pigtails and bangs like um
name a grown woman rocking bangs yeah
well I mean Rachel always ask me about
that should I get bangs I'm like no I
don't know although if you wanted not to
get hit on but she said
girl you know what it's so hot to me
dreads
future you know when you wear baggy
clothes yeah uh I bring a nun outfit out
you know what's cute a habit you know
I'm vibing with lately I'm the Arabic
culture they just cover their face yeah
you show your eyes
um I think that
um
I think that it's one of those things
that you gotta be able to pull off but
it's not necessarily something that is
something that guys like bangs I think
women are like oh cute bangs but you're
talking to your first of all all the
[ __ ] that they do is just for them
true yeah they know us like I don't how
many how often are you like you might
your girl gets her hair done right and
you just kind of go oh it looks great
you know because but it's just like it
all looks great right yeah but they
doing this for like well I wanted to do
this don't say doing the [ __ ] for me
because it looks fun everything you
everything you do looks great you know
so I don't know what hair like what
hairstyle have you ever thought maybe
you have a preference you might be like
oh I like when you do your hair like
right or different colors my girl likes
to dye your hair I'm like do this color
I'm her Kanye she's skin all right I
dress her oh wow oh wow that sounds
scary I'm gonna I want to dye my hair
[ __ ] just all done my hair with you
I've never dyed my hair in my life I've
dyed mine uh I've used to put more I
felt like I was getting like too great
so I would die because I had my mustache
died like because Just For Men yeah
because I was even on when I was doing
I'm dying up here when I was doing I'm
dying up here it had to be dark you know
so then right you're doing stuff and
even oh my God actually that looks kind
of cool thanks man yeah I look like
Anderson Cooper on steroids yeah it's
cool yeah yeah I look like it just
sucked I just don't like when people do
that and then their their facial hair
isn't the problem is is I win the ocean
I want to go gray on my top right
because there's too much I think I'd
look cool I think I'd look better with
great I think I'll look I want to be
gray I think you should go die here all
silver yeah you know what I would do
that that looks so dope I'm gonna try to
do that he'll look like Rogue see I went
in the ocean then my hair just went it
went really South I guess you're not
supposed to go in the ocean with your
hair done nobody told me oh really okay
and it goes green right or something it
was a nightmare yeah yeah the colors
here what should you do you have to like
shave your head or something or what'd
you do I just laughed and looked like
[ __ ] yeah I said like a big gay guy
uh what's up boys Isaiah from California
La checking in with you guys with the
King there or sting it you're from
Irvine anime I know it's become more
amazing recently
um and I know Theo's probably saying
something about me just watching myself
draw but yeah it's become more
mainstream I like it you know what's
weird about anime is there's anime porn
who's watching cartoons [ __ ] yeah no I
don't I don't understand that and you
know what you know what that was that
was a bait that was a bait I knew you do
yeah of course you do I don't understand
it at all I don't understand
and it's like like all the tentacles are
in every single hole what are you doing
women are being hurt
what do you say to that you know oh yeah
me too man yeah yeah challenges right
yeah yeah [ __ ] now
um hey by being hurt you mean giant big
dicks I think they signed up for that
dude no but everyone's having fun it's
not necessarily true and then only fans
comes along and they have all ownership
of it what are we doing here there's
Millions I think a lot of those women
would rather be scientists
I think you'd be surprised it's just
harder to be a science
wow wait can I tell you something yeah
that was the best backhanded compliment
yeah like that was that was spectacular
well you're welcome I honestly that was
that was one of your best yeah thank you
um that would be signed I I think that
uh and who like you're watching you're
watching porn you see like the Family
Guy porn on the the banner who who the
[ __ ] clicks on that okay no I don't know
what you like you like the weird like is
this by David Cronenberg type [ __ ]
yeah yeah it's like there's a good story
on it it's like it doesn't even start
until 30 minutes in yeah yeah it's like
there's a thing like you know like this
kid was left some place but Eric you'll
actually fight through them and you love
Yakuza is there yeah yeah yeah and you
love sounds like this
you know what I mean you love that kind
of [ __ ] you like like the alien pool
yeah he likes it oh I like the aliens
but are you watching it just for uh for
the story you're actually just yeah oh
no yeah I've had to get his dick how do
you get Miles by a cartoon yep I mean
well he's Twisted yeah he's Twisted
there you go uh and it's all good we're
all twisted in our own ways but his [ __ ]
yeah you're gonna judge me no no no no
[ __ ] no no no no no I mean a matter of
fact a little as a matter of fact the
fact that you like that gets me [ __ ]
horny
next week
should I have bangs now
um yeah one more hottest cartoon is
Jessica right oh it's Justin Timberlake
yo guys it's your boy Patrick from the
UK I mean obviously
camping at music festivals or staying in
a hotel
if you camp you get the true Festival is
someone else operating this guy dirty
smelly I think that's what it's all
about yeah hostage
freshen up for the next day
always stay clean always look your best
he's so nervous
um let me know what you guys think boys
so nervous I want to tell you this the
only party wasn't nervous was the
singing part no I think it makes you
feel good by the way can I say can I can
I go for a second here sure
um you have to stay in the hotel bro
because look to the right of him he's
got a little baby carriage thing right
there so you're not gonna be out camping
if you're out at a music festival with
your kids well he might be home now and
he has the kids talking about before
he's on a hotel he's talking about
camping or hotel well if you go to like
if you go to a burning man right you
have to take an RV or I guess you could
stay in a hotel and go track through the
night I don't know how it works neither
do I and I'm not I'm not I'm not about
that life no way bro I'm not about that
life yeah but to me camping is the same
as getting a uh what a thing you like to
get he don't like hotels
you know well you like airbnb's yeah
although I did an Airbnb thank you oh
yeah no [ __ ] Airbnb Ontario my daddy
stay in a hotel in uh Boston no no like
I've got no sleep in there bro Airbnb
club's in the hotel so you you know what
I mean it's a great Hotel you never know
what you're gonna get with an Airbnb
yeah you do and you got to clear out all
the moths and spiders and [ __ ] what
Airbnb did you run no no [ __ ] nice
house you know what though his thing is
not about the the difference his thing
is about he wants other people with him
you don't like being alone oh yeah you
just get adjoining rooms bro
I hate when you go to a hotel [ __ ]
stump them and you want to get adjoining
rooms and they make a big deal out of it
oh I know like what like let's say we're
all let's say we go on a tour or
something we're going to do comedy which
we might do uh guy from Workaholics
wants a joining room what do you mean
they may get a [ __ ] big deal out of
it no no they they make it out like it's
like they can't do it uh they're always
kind of like oh well we don't have we
can put you on the same floor yeah like
[ __ ] give me the [ __ ] adjoining
one [ __ ] I got problems I need to
[ __ ] connect
[Laughter]
hey Eric you still jacking off the anime
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
um
you always you always are the grossest
on the show hey you pushing me towards
it so all right fair enough you know
what I mean fair enough it's me too you
poked it back I take you poked the bear
you get to
the dumbest quote wait all right so
uh yeah well what if they well hold on a
second though what if they don't have a
joining rooms left but they but why my
thing is like it's like how about this
you see three I'm coming on a
reservation I book a reservation with
this hotel and this clearly says I want
three rooms
[ __ ]
that should be
again yeah all right you know that's a
good point why the [ __ ] are you giving
us words that's all over the place
that's true you know what I mean they
don't want to do the extra work that it
takes to [ __ ] you know what I said I
get that I I need the rooms joined and
they go we can't do that
yeah yeah okay no but I I I'm just
saying it's like yeah so I would be in a
hotel I don't care where I'm going I
like being in a hotel but if I'm with my
friends by the way too though I don't
know if I wanna like it he needs a he
would be good for adjoining rooms
because he wants his yeah but like
sometimes I don't want to be on the even
on the same
same yeah wise right yeah I don't want
to be near you no yeah we just found out
he's a serial killer but yeah yeah yeah
uh you know floor 10 you on the left I I
understand yeah it doesn't want us
judging them no I do I don't need to be
I don't need to be a joint yeah I I like
I'm thinking about when I go on the road
I I now I bring uh Lulu and Mike linochi
like I don't need to be on the same
floor as them yeah well although I do
bring my family a lot so obviously they
don't have different floors cows on
floor too I'm on floor tests
what I'm saying in that situation you
get in two rooms maybe you do want to
have an adjoining room because you have
your you know what I mean yes yeah yeah
yeah sweet or something I don't know I
just I just feel like I don't I hate if
there's any hotel people out there why
don't you just give the damn adjoining
rooms why is it always a freaking hassle
I tell you why I think I think it's
because a computer does it when you
order the thing they just pick the
[ __ ] rooms oh I think they don't want
to give you anything extra it feels like
you're getting something like you know
you're getting something extra like
let's say the room is 200 a night and
now you have two rooms it feels like
by the way I always want to get the
sweet dude I try I'm going to Adam Ray's
wedding are you guys you're you're not
buddy yeah I know I know you're cool
with them but you're not you're going to
the wedding yeah yeah yeah you're going
yeah I'll [ __ ] yeah cool dude
right it's very rare go to win yeah I
didn't want to go to my grandma's
funeral my dad's give me a gift yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know yeah
um but uh yeah I think the [ __ ]
hotel's already sold out it's a [ __ ]
did you get your room yet no I didn't oh
right did you be upset but he said that
there's like three hotels that everyone
started well because I want to get a
suite what city
oh no no I know it'll be fine no but his
particular hotel where the wedding is
but he did say I don't know if the
wedding is at a hotel or not do you know
yeah I think it is I think it's at this
spot that's annoying God damn it all
right whatever can you tell me what
hotel you're going to go into I don't
know yeah but I will I don't know yet oh
but I'll tell you yeah yeah different
floors but did you see this uh campaign
ad that Adam Ray posted uh you know what
I talked about it on my podcast but I
haven't seen it I talked about it on
congratulations if you want the real
real hit heat go on over to
congratulations super cool Studios And
subscribe but we can talk about it here
secondarily
this is real yeah
hey Utah District 12. listen up right
here there's a new name on the ballot
for the Senate this year my name is
Linda Paulson slow motion an awesome
love God and family and the Constitution
doesn't rhyme
nobody could do it so I'm getting it
done it's working off two guys
Pro police the right to bear arms and
the right to free speech okay I like it
watch us watch watch and want to stop
and expose all politics watch this watch
this watch us
watch this ready here we go program
should
and support traditional families
of society but in schools they are
pushing for new beliefs she so you know
she's so racist yeah like yeah I'm
voting even that's my vote if you even
say blacks around her she goes like this
no even worship even worse she goes like
this give me a beat
and her husband goes
corruption
hey I'm all about family I think that
that's like awesome good for her for
trying to reach young people and be
outside the box yeah it's not you know
it's just like when Marvel made the
[ __ ] uh or uh not Marvel uh they've
on Pixar made the [ __ ] light year
with the game and everyone's like what
are you doing it's so [ __ ]
transparent like just stick to your [ __ ]
up because we're talking about it yeah
she got my vote you're not gonna win
though bro with my help she might why
not this in Utah I'm in Salt Lake City
in October Wise Guys I'm gonna have her
do five minutes
um just have her do the song but yeah I
will be in Raleigh North Carolina so
it's crazy yeah she's not there she's in
Salt Lake City and I'm there in October
that's being transparently can we just
do the dates at a certain time oh no I
don't want anything you talk about bangs
cool I'm in [ __ ] Boston now yeah I
found it Saturday Boston I'll be there
too all right all right Colusa Casino
area
Ontario Improv coming up that it was
just there Inland Empire so look for you
know I'm gonna have all that on
airgriffin.com later this later I also
watch You Now by now I actually also
will be at uh I'm doing the Tempe Improv
I picked it up I'm doing the the two
nights before Adam Ray's wedding it's
gang Fest actually the day before Adam
Ray's wedding I'm gonna be in Colusa
Casino oh so the 28 because ways on the
29th yeah on the side of whatever that
sounds yeah you guys get into detail
about that wedding but yeah so I think
it starts to be also be it's gang Fest
so come check me out there too in Vegas
Escape first all right there you go man
thanks guys that's it kids thanks for
watching liking subscribing and then you
can head on over here we're gonna run it
we're running now baby yeah you're
talking about the pages well yeah you're
cutting me off so it's very it's highly
annoying but uh
no no Adam Ray's wedding patreon people
that's in the comments Brandon's cutting
people up it's okay it's one of his
things it's what I do it's what he does
and we [ __ ] hoop someone it's all you
know
um patreon patreon yeah cats plus
they're called the Cubbies no I don't I
don't agree I thought we meant it wasn't
Cubbies Club yeah I don't I also don't
like that but whatever it is we'll
figure it out and you can join the
patreon extra episode we just vote how
about we have the patreon people oh
that's what we'll come up with this you
tell them what to do you don't all right
you know what we'll talk about this
we'll talk about it all right we'll talk
about I'll be in Boston next week
Thursday Friday Saturday after San Jose
then Salt Lake City in Stockton and
Oakland oh my God
this is as far as I can get stocked in
an open I'll be there Friday Saturday
baby oh my God what well you know chin
can suck himself
[ __ ] yeah in Irvine
she's gotta have your big nuts out like
that there we go this is [ __ ]
incredible it feels good dude it looks
like somebody else how do you even oh my
God I can't I'm not gonna I think those
are my legs I just embarrass myself and
do that yeah I can't do it all right
don't forget I'm gonna work on it though
again we're chilling baby I'm built
crystallia built for gay
[Music]
how many times I gotta make this song
wait I get the gist I just probably have
to slow it down and hit it like this
[Music]
thing in the way let's go legendary
[Music]